welcome back to Las Vegas now actor and
comedian London Browns story will remind
you that success doesn't happen
overnight but the journey the journey is
good for the soul you'll see what I did
there here's our conversation about his
journey and where you can catch him next
we're talking HBO ballers to American
soul give us the background of your
career and you know introduce us to
yourself share what London Brown or in
the social media world I'm at real
London Brown from South Central LA and
born and raised and basically just early
on a new I want to be some sort of
artist but in high school is where I
discovered where I really tapped into
one to do this thing called acting
somewhere near they had a talent show
the talent show was to raise money for
the kids comedy show and I think I
inquired about it and then the principal
sign me up I wanna do in the show like
oh this is what I'm supposed to do most
do stand-up your nose out those are real
bad eyes then let me get on
[Applause]
let me get a clown dive are ya it stuck
received me we started talking the
exchange numbers
he says hey you want to open for me I
start talking with Chris Tucker in the
process of that I do a showcase called
the CBS diversity showcase I guess maybe
a year later I get a call someone says
HBO is looking for me I said okay I do
the audition I do the audition book that
got moved to Miami to film ballers are
in the middle of shooting ballers that
brings us up to I get a call from Robbie
Reed which he's great friend of mine she
said hey American soul we would like you
to come in and play boozy Collins let's
talk more about American soul and what
people can expect it comes out on it
starts on May 27th right everybody wants
to be on Soul Train time people trying
to get ahead on my show and I think
people gonna enjoy it and is it's a dope
throwback this is just different and any
people see me in a totally different
light than what they used to seeing from
ballers or from the other stuff that
they watch it's totally different that's
the quick short story of kind of what's
happening with me and I work with kids
you know still get juvenile hall stuff
like that and I do a lot of work with
homeless people because I believe you
know I believe in doing things that keep
my heart in check so that's my story
who was that inspiration for you as far
as installation I've always looked at
people's careers that I've always
admired like I like the fact about I
took a little bit of from everybody like
Chris Turk and one from stand up into
the films and I look at people like a
Will Smith was always positive and
moving forward I want you to be like yo
he played this he played the dad there
was some drama there was this and I want
to keep that going you got levels
versatility you know what again no but
inspiring story you watch Soul Train
growing up JC
absolutely back in Philly for sure
keep up with London at real London Brown
and catch him on the season two of BT's
American soul starting tomorrow night
and obviously just a quick season one
binge watch to catch up we have